it's cool when you see like a sweet dog
and that instinct comes out that killer
wolf instin comes out around squirrels
they're just and then they see a [__]
squirrel and they lock in and they just
want to
murder my dog did that to a skunk
recently oh no yeah it's my first brush
with that it is brutal dude skunks are
effective I mean this happened like a
couple months ago my dog still smells
like a homeless person it's like a
homeless person sleeping in my house
it's so crazy how effective that smell
is it was so funny to watch she saw this
skunk and I could see in her mind she
was going like oh it's just like a tiny
little squirrel I'm about to [__] this
[__] up skunks are badass dude they're
like the NRA gun carrying Republicans of
the animal kingdom cuz my dog's ready to
[__] do jiujitsu [__] it up and that
skunk just went I wouldn't do that if I
was you I'm strapped my dog lunges and
the skunk just turns around and [__]
laser beam diarrhea shot right in the
face dude you were there for the whole
thing I saw the whole thing dude they're
the only animal that's strapped yeah
they got a gun true and it's effective
Bear yeah and I read like less than four
or five% of skunks get killed by
Predators like it's a really effective
defense mechanism yeah and they're tiny
and and then the skunk after he sprayed
the dog he just kind of walked away like
business as usual another [__]
stepped up and found
out
yeah